on va plus loin comme chaque soir donc à
20h40 heures de Paris retour sur deux
informations qui ont marqué ces
dernières heures en compagnie ce soir de
notre chroniqueur internationale
gauthierebinsky bonsoir Gauthier et de
Patricia à lemonnière grand-père bonsoir
à vous également Patricia merci d'être
avec nous on va plus loin tout d'abord
ce soir sur ses premiers pas hors
d'Italie pour la nouvelle présidente du
conseil d'extrême droite Giorgia Meloni
1er déplacement à l'étranger réservé
donc à Bruxelles elle a rencontré
aujourd'hui les dirigeants des
principales institutions européennes
conseils par le manque commission très
symbolique donc et scruté de près les
prises de position et les décisions à
venir de celle qui était jusqu'à lors la
dirigeante du parti post fasciste
Fratelli d'Italia inquiète alors on
essaye Patricia de garder la face à
Bruxelles de dire qu'on va coopérer avec
Georgia Meloni elle met elle-même à
parler il y a quelques instants je la
cite d'entretien franc et positif avec
les dirigeants européens malgré tout son
accession de pouvoir inquiète alors elle
ne peut elle ne veut qu'avoir des
entretiens francs et positifs avec les
dirigeants européens parce qu'elle a
définitivement besoin de la Manu
européenne pour sortir son pays sans
pays qui est endetté on le sait 190
milliards de dettes un PIB 150 % de la
du PIB justement elle a besoin de se
plomb de ce fameux plan d'aide européen
elle a déjà touché les délais déjà
touché 50 milliards pour en toucher bien
plus dites-nous donc largement
bénéficiaire 200 milliards et donc
d'euros d'aide pour l'Italie sur 800
milliards sur le paquet de jeu global
cet argent donc elle veut donner des
gages alors sur le plan international
pur ce qui concerne la politique
étrangère de l'Europe je crois que ce
sera pas trop difficile en revanche ce
qui sera difficile c'est ce qui inquiète
les Européens c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement même en Méditerranée je
pense alors on reparlera avec le fameux
bateau on va y vivre en tout cas là les
inquiétudes dans l'immédiat disons
Gautier c'est plutôt sur le plan
économique notamment ce sa feuille de
route budgétaire Meloni oui d'abord
parce que si vous voulez il est toujours
très facile quand on est démagogique et
populiste de dire je vais vous donner ce
que vous voulez ce que vous réclamez et
puis c'est les autres qui payeront
quitte à ce que d'ailleurs et c'est
typique de l'extrême droite on crache
dans la soupe
l'Europe
incarne tous les mots mais la bonne
soupe on en a besoin alors ça c'est la
première remarque la deuxième remarque
c'est que Ina échappé à personne que
Silvio berlusconita un des piliers de
cette coalition avec son sourire figé
jusqu'aux oreilles et si heureux
d'ailleurs ils sont inséreux et café
ballusconi pendant des années quand il a
été au pouvoir accumuler les dettes
être jugé et condamné pour corruption
qu'il n'a jamais payé et toutes ces
parce qu'il y a eu pire il y a eu le
harcèlement sexuel il y a eu toutes ces
choses là c'est vous balustcogni avait
fini par rendre le pays italien l'Italie
totalement inattractive en terme
d'investisseurs parce qu'on avait peur
de ce qui pouvait se passer quand il
mettait la main dans un dossier ou dans
une affaire donc cet homme là a
discrédité l'Italie l'a fait s'endetter
et maintenant vous avez donc George
abelon qui dit au secours il faut nous
renflouer elle a raison bien sûr qu'on
va pas laisser tomber l'Italie mais
enfin combat les que les Italiens que le
régime italien actuel balait devant sa
porte ben Luce conique est toujours là
et d'ailleurs qui était indispensable
pour la victoire de George jameloni de
fratellinitalia et bien il est toujours
là il est responsable d'une grande part
de du marasme économique et budgétaire
italiens donc voilà vous voyez quand on
dit les gens nouveaux arrivent au
pouvoir ah oui ils sont pas si nouveau
que ça et ils ont des en tout cas
aujourd'hui c'est un numéro
d'équilibriste assez difficile auquel
elle doit se livrer Patricia entre donc
cette nécessité de rassurer Bruxelles et
notamment sur le plan
budgétaire et économique mais de tenir
aussi c'est les promesses qu'elle a fait
à ces électeurs c'est le grand écart
parce qu'effectivement visite ces
électeurs elle leur a promis des
allégements d'impôts des subventions des
aides etc et beaucoup de dépenses et
c'est bien ce qui inquiète effectivement
l'Union européenne comment va-t-elle
pouvoir rentrer dans les critères et ne
pas faire encore que la dette encore
s'accentue parce que qui dit d'être
important et bien dit les taux de prêt à
l'Italie augmente etc donc c'est un
circuit sans fin qui qui s'enclenche
mais je crois que
nos problèmes avec Giorgia Meloni les
problèmes de l'Europe ne viendront pas
tant je crois des c'est une femme
pragmatique à ce niveau là mais il
viendront vraiment des problèmes sociaux
et des problèmes migratoires là que les
gros problèmes vont se poser avec
l'Europe je crois beaucoup plus que sur
ces questions budgétaires ou ma foi elle
s'est entourée de ministres tout à fait
qui sont des proches de draguer en
quelque sorte et donc elle va elle va
gérer bon peut-être pas gérer le
mécontentement qui va naître du fait
parce que si elle ne délivre pas comme
disent les Anglais toutes ces promesses
effectivement les Italiens vont être
mécontents mais je crois qu'elle sera
fait parce qu'elle va leur donner des
gages sur le plan sociétal parce que
personne n'a intérêt à ce que l'Italie
plonge
sur le plan européen sur le plan même
humain donc tout est fait pour que les
choses se passent entre guillemets bien
et que d'ailleurs ça lui permette de
conduire même avec un conséquence et
incohérence une certaine politique donc
ça veut dire qu'elle sera maintenue à
flot par l'Europe
sur le plan migratoire
sur ce plan migratoire elle veut réviser
les règles sur le débarquement des
migrants les migrants qui font encore
l'actualité aujourd'hui on en parlait il
y a quelques minutes sur ce sujet ça va
ça va coincer ça va coincer ça sais pas
comment c'est à coincer avec l'Allemagne
en particulier parce que ce bateau
allemand enfin sous pavillon allemand
qui a de son de sang et quelques
migrants qui demandent 134 234 qui
demande à Coster elle renvoie tout ça et
elle a l'idée elle est norvégien aussi
qui demande un costaud enfin tous ces
bateaux à peu près avec 1000 migrants là
qui sont autour et qui demandent un
Coster se tourne vers la France
l'Espagne en disant on peut pas être la
Grèce longtemps la Grèce et cetera
des nous distingue pas de les débarquer
en espagnol en France ils disent
aidez-nous à trouver une solution et
donc elle ce qu'elle est très elle est
très simple parce qu'elle dit elle dit
c'est des bateaux qui ont un drapeau et
bien c'est le pays qui a le drapeau qui
doit les accueillir première chose
deuxième chose qu'elle dit elle ressort
une vieille idée qui avait déjà été
utilisée par un précédent ministre de
l'Intérieur que je ne citerai pas et
donc qui est de faire des hotspots en
Libye et de gérer avec les les milices
libyennes et les trafiquants d'être
humain c'est ça qu'elle propose je vais
gérer avec les trafiquants d'être humain
en Libye on va installer des petits
camps ils vont nous bloquer et échanges
je vais vous donner de l'argent alors si
c'est de l'argent qui vient de l'Europe
là je crois que les européens seront pas
très contents d'alimenter les caisses
des des miliciens et des trafiquants
d'armes Libya bien que n'est ce pas
Gauthier bien sûr en tout allez-y c'est
exactement ce que vient de dire patricia
est exactement la preuve du de
l'inconséquence crasse d'une politique
d'extrême droite qui consiste à dire oui
avec l'argent je peux commettre toutes
les immoralités possibles du moment que
je me fiche éperdument du sort des
hommes et des femmes qui sont dans ses
bateaux voilà l'hypocrisie totale hein
ça consiste à mettre le sort d'être
humain sous le tapis comme on balance la
poussière et après en disant je sors le
carnet de chèques et tout va bien et
qu'un échec européen et le carnet de
chaque européen en plus alors sur cette
question migratoire elle est en phase
disons avec les autres membres de sa
coalition ultra conservatrice donc je le
rappelle
qui unit donc Fratelli d'Italie à la
Ligue de Matteo Salvini à Forza Italia
de Silvio Berlusconi cette coalition sur
d'autres sujets européens ou sur la
politique étrangère
voilà expose au grand jour pas mal de
divergences est-ce que cette coalition
pourra durer vous pensez dans le temps
alors elle est fragile elle est fragile
en particulier parce que il y a les
alliés
de du Premier ministre italien qui ne
partage pas toutes ces positions sur
l'Europe et sur l'Ukraine et vis-à-vis
de la Russie on a bien vu Sergio
Berlusconi qui s'affiait là encore en
disant je suis le meilleur ami de
Vladimir Poutine donc effectivement il y
a des vraies fractures et sur le temps
aussi il y a des vraies factures mais
est-ce qu'ils ne vont pas vouloir jouer
leur survie vous savez les hommes
politiques sont des animaux et la survie
chez un animal est primordial donc tant
que ils peuvent vivre ensemble et ma foi
faire le gros dos je pense que cette
coalition qu'on disait très fragile va
peut-être être plus solide
paradoxalement parce que c'est tout
simplement la survie que je des hommes
parce que ils n'ont pas eu de si bons
résultats à un espagotier aux élections
oui c'est plus Georgia Meloni qui a mené
la danse et qui a décidé sans doute
aujourd'hui
un mot peut-être de tous ces pays alors
au de la même de l'Italie on pense
notamment à la Hongrie ou encore on
parlait hier ensemble Gautier du
Danemark ou c'est une gauche qui a
remporté les législatives mais avec un
programme très très à droite voilà
notamment sur cette question à nouveau
de l'immigration
comment expliquer cette extrême
droiteisation
je ne serai pas ici je veux dire par là
qu'on pourrait on pourrait penser à
autre chose c'est très compliqué parce
que c'est vrai qu'il y a des facteurs
régionaux et locaux à chaque fois on a
bien vu qu'au Danemark il y avait ce qui
était né c'était une peur de la perte de
l'État-providence c'est pas la même
chose en Pologne loin de là c'est pas la
même chose en Hongrie ce qu'on peut
remarquer comme point commun à chaque
fois c'est une forme de d'abord de
cynisme par rapport à l'histoire volonté
de de l'histoire de d'inconstances dans
la manière de représenter de défendre
ses opinions vous voyez bien la lâcheté
du député RN à Paris qui qui ne
reconnaît même pas ce qu'il a dit ce
qu'ils ont pas le courage de leur
opinions et ça c'est pareil aussi avec
l'extrême droite européenne c'est
toujours les autres qui ont fait quelque
chose là dans le cas italien il y a
quelque chose qui me semble
particulièrement cynique et ça rejoint
ce que disait Patricia mais c'est pas
incompatible totalement c'est que par
rapport à l'actualité internationale
vous avez dans un pouvoir italien comme
celui-ci aujourd'hui finalement il y
aurait entre guillemets le mauvais flic
et le bon flic vous savez il y a celui
qui se serait proche de l'OTAN et puis
comme on met pas tous ses œufs dans le
même panier et ben on aurait Matéo
Salvini pour pour fréquenter Poutine et
puis on voit après on voit qui joue qui
remporte la donne qui est en forme qui
n'est pas en forme et comme ça le
gouvernement italien pose fasciste ou
d'extrême droite se donne une marge de
manœuvre et comme ça il est jamais pris
au dépourvu c'est un petit peu ça aussi
diffusé hier est devenu virale qui
montre une dizaine de membres de force
de sécurité passées à tabac un homme au
sol selon l'ongrin Human Rights basé à
Oslo la répression a fait au moins 277
morts depuis bientôt deux mois les
manifestations se poursuivent malgré
tout dans le pays elle commence même ces
manifestations à prendre de nouvelles
formes un Gauthier
oui elles prennent de nouvelles formes
et
ce que je crains moi c'est qu'on en
parle de moins en moins or si vous
voulez ce qui est important dans ce qui
se passe en Iran d'abord mais ça je
pense que Patricia on parlera mieux que
moi c'est que on est dans une révolte
parfois même ça peut ressembler à une
insurrection qui n'est plus une
insurrection de la fin ou de la vie
chère ou du manque de de tel ou tel
considération là on est dans la défense
du caractère humain ça commence par les
femmes évidemment et vous avez vu les
hommes ne s'y trompent pas en tout cas
ceux qui veulent changer les choses ont
emboîté le pas il y a donc là une
revendication politique qui est
fondamentale et énorme quand vous
entendez par exemple des manifestants
demandés le départ ça serait peut-être
dans des conditions plutôt douces mais
de d'abattre le régime d'abattre le
guide suprême qui effectivement
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce régime
sclérosé qui est patriarcal et qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec quelle idée de
révolution que ce soit et d'ailleurs sur
lequel l'Occident s'est complètement
planté puisque on a cru voir en 7 19
dans la révolution islamique un pied né
aux Américains oui c'en est éteint et
pour instaurer quelque chose qui est
presque pire que l'impérialisme
américain donc voilà pourquoi moi
personnellement je voulais revenir sur
ce sur ce sujet parce que vous l'avez
dit il y a cette vidéo insoutenable la
tension ou le respect que nous portons à
nos spectateurs fait qu'on a diffuse pas
mais elle est proprement insoutenable et
elle fait comprendre des choses
des milliers Patricia des milliers de
personnes auraient été arrêté je le
disais depuis deux mois depuis le début
de ces manifestations dont l'origine
et la mort donc de cette jeune Marsa à
mini la justice iranienne a visiblement
inculpé déjà un millier de personnes
pour leur participation en tout cas
c'est c'est un peu c'est l'accusation
pour leur participation à ses émeutes
qu'attendre de cette justice alors déjà
les procès ont commencé il y en a eu je
crois 4 et déjà il y aurait eu un
condamné à mort
mais
cette justice est une arme aux mains des
autorités de les juges ont des mots
d'ordre très clairs ont reçu des maux
d'or de ne pas être Clément d'être dur
d'appliquer les peines les plus
rigoureuses qu'est-ce que c'est la peine
la plus rigoureuse en Iran c'est la
peine de mort et pour ce régime la vie
de ses concitoyens largement ne jouent
pas simplement ils sont un peu pris en
ce moment dans un étau parce que ce sont
des jeunes qui manifestent
essentiellement il n'y a pas que des
jeunes je veux pas mais le mouvement
vient de la jeunesse cette jeunesse
pourquoi elle manifeste parce que elle
c'est une jeunesse qui n'a plus d'espoir
et qui n'a pas peur qui a eu peur c'est
ceux qui ont fait les anciennes révoltes
et qui ont été réprimés très sévèrement
de 2009 et ont vu dans leur chair à quel
point le régime pouvait être cruel
violent etc ils l'ont vu donc ils aussi
connu la guerre ils ont aussi connu 1979
la répression tout ce qui est donc les
parents et les grands-parents sont
habités par une espèce de peur que les
jeunes n'ont plus qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent les jeunes ils veulent pas le
temps la révolution qu'on pourrait
imaginer ils veulent tout simplement
vivre les filles veulent l'enlever leur
voile et les gamins ils veulent vivre
comme tous les jeunes de leur époque
c'est ça la critique majeure du régime
alors ce régime il est bien embêté et il
va devoir trouver une porte de sortie
parce qu'il va pas pouvoir tous les tuer
parce qu'il en a besoin il a parce que
c'est des jeunes souvent et des
étudiants donc ces jeunes étudiants en a
besoin pour refaire ces ingénieurs qui
justement travaillent dans les
laboratoires etc il a besoin de cette
élite là il a besoin de les phagocytes
donc le régime aujourd'hui est acculé là
il doit trouver une porte de sortie le
problème est Gauthier va seulement
revenir dessus c'est que les passes
d'Aran ne sont toujours pas encore
entrées vraiment en action et le jour
ils rentrons en action ça se trouve
autre chose que des bassidy je pense
autre actualité concernant l'Iran sur
laquelle je voulais de revenir avec vous
on a largement parlé sur notre antenne
Téhéran fournirait des drones à la
Russie dans le cadre de la guerre en
Ukraine ce nouvel axe Téhéran Moscou
semble Gauthier se renforcer en ce
moment les cartes sont un peu rebatures
en terme Gémeaux géopolitique mais vous
avez raison d'en parler dans ces termes
parce que tout cela se tient que
sommes-nous en train de vivre si je vous
les citer Léo Ferré je dirais que nous
vivons une époque épique mais que nous
n'avons plus rien des pics et que nous
ne savons pas faire les liens que se
passe-t-il en Iran vous voyez bien le
régime d'emola dit ne venez pas nous
chercher des poux dans la tête avec ce
qui se passe en interne parce que sinon
on pourrait faire pire avec les Russes
vous voyez comment ça fonctionne aussi
alors évidemment on dira mais oui les
Russes et les Iraniens sont associés et
notamment aussi parce que ils ont
contribué à désherber complètement sur
le plan le plus humain possible la Syrie
et ça leur ça leur convient de même que
ça va convenir parfaitement au nouveau
gouvernement israélien qui se dit c'est
peut-être les Iraniens mais au moins on
est tranquille on n'a pas de problème et
il vaut mieux d'ailleurs
merci à vous aussi Patricia pour vos
éclairages ce soir cette ce module est à
retrouver bien sûr sur notre site
Internet ainsi que sur nos réseaux
sociaux restés avec nous sur France 24
l'actualité se poursuit tout de suite
[Musique]